-Hey!
-Oh, come on, you look great!
Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
What -- I love the hair,
or the non-hair. What --
-The non-hair. It's growing out
just a little bit right now.
Thank you.
I'm loving it, too.
My man cut it for me last week.
I am, like, cutting it
every two weeks.
-Is this something you
always wanted to do?
-Well, yeah, I always wanted
to do it.
For years I've been talking
about cutting my hair.
And you know, this whole
quarantine
and everything made me think,
like, "Well, why not now?"
I'm not going to be on any
red carpets.
And if I have to be on
something,
they always put me in wigs
anyways.
And the wigs sit better.
And so I was just like, yeah,
let's just go for it.
And I did it online
so everybody could see,
because I wanted to know what I
look like from my head to toe.
Like, who am I
from head to toe?
You know, every religion
talks about knowing thy self.
And I know where
all my moles are
except for the ones
that were on my head.
And now I know I got two moles
on my head.
It's a little wrinkly
in the back.
You know, and --
When it's all the way gone...
-You know you.
-...it's very smooth.
My head kind of feels
like a penis.
And that's kinda nice.
-Wow.
-It's kinda nice.
-Okay, I'll take it.
I love that.
-That might have been too far,
but I'm just sharing
the knowledge.
I'm learning new things about
myself every day
now that I'm bald-headed,
you know, like --
-I know you did
stand-up again.
I want to say, how did it feel
to be in front of a crowd?
An audience?
-It was amazing.
Like, the best sex ever. Okay?
-[ Laughing ]
-It was the best.
Like, to be in front of
that live audience.
And granted,
everyone had on masks,
so you couldn't hear
the laughter right away,
but you could see it.
Everybody'd get a little
squinty eyes
when they laugh, and their
heads are bobbing
and hands are clapping.
And so you find new cues
to accept.
And I just -- by the end of it,
I felt like a Care Bear.
I felt like I was doing, like,
the Care Bear stare
where you're just like,
"Yes, jokes, jokes, jokes!"
-Everybody's getting
beamed out.
Oh, I love it.
[ Laughs ]
It was so good.
It was so amazing.
-The last time you were here,
we talked about
your special, "Black Mitzvah,"
and it was right
before it came out.
And now it is Emmy-nominated
"Black Mitzvah."
So congratulations, you got
nominated for an Emmy!
-Thank you.
You know, it's so awesome
to be recognized by my peers.
That's, like, amazing.
And the same day that I found
out, I felt very grateful.
But I went to the mailbox,
and there was all these
handwritten notes
from these foster youth
that I have been talking to
over the quarantine.
I've been Zoom-calling with
a bunch of foster kids
in different group homes.
And it was 40 messages,
40 little handwritten notes
and cards, and they, like, drew
on them and colored them,
and that was the best
award ever.
Like, that was better
than anything.
And, like, when I get down,
I just open those up
and read them.
It's like, that's better than
any trophy I could ever get.
-Oh, I love it.
-To be recognized by, you know,
our youth, our future.
-Good for you for doing that.
That's so cool that you do that.
And that's the reward.
It's so cool.
I love it.
-Yeah, it's great.
-How has your -- has
your stand-up changed
since the pandemic
and, obviously,
the protests
for social justice?
-Well, definitely.
You know, people are
always asking me,
"Tiffany, what can we do?
What can we do to
make change in --"
And what I've incorporated
in my comedy
is something that I think
that would work,
that would change
the systemic racism
and the injustices
that we all suffer.
And I think the key to it is
all women
just stop having sex.
Everyone just close their legs,
just shut it down.
Men will get -- I know this has
happened in history before.
Wars have stopped
because of this.
If every woman just said,
"That's it, I'm closing my legs
until justice is served,
until there is change,"
then things will be great.
Now the Karens will be
overwhelmed
because they don't want
change, right?
The Karens want things
to stay the same.
So the Karens are
going to be overwhelmed,
and after so long,
they're going to be like,
"Look, okay, we got to start
voting, people."
Karens are going to be out there
getting people
registered to vote.
They're going to be talking to
black people, Spanish people.
They're going to be talking
to --
Karens are going to be like,
"Look, I know, I was talking
crazy a few months ago --"
-Now --
-"But I cannot handle
all this sex that I got to do
because everybody
shut their legs closed.
So, please, please
register to vote.
Please, let's make some change."
-Wow, that is the way to do it.
That's the way to get
some change.